let's talk golf today is National Golf
day it's a perfect time to perfect your
swing so the valley has all kinds of
golf courses to practice but one spot
focuses on the fun and that's where
Candace Charles is Top Golf behind the
strip showing off her Chip Shot hey
Candace
good morning YouTube good morning folks
yeah this is the place to come and have
a little fun and also learn about the
game they have something for children
for adults and you can get a lesson with
a pro golfer I have here one here with
me now director of instruction for
Topgolf Lindsey Hoskins thank you so
much for joining us tell us a little bit
about the lessons here yeah so we
provide lessons to any age and ability
level so really what we like to do is
start with fundamentals and then just go
from there so work on the swing I know
we've been working a little bit this
morning but you know just kind of the
fundamentals are always first and
foremost and then we just go from there
all right we're going to give you guys a
quick example of a lesson and I do have
to hand the room I'm at guys so here you
go Lindsay all right all right what is
the first thing about we always work on
grip so of course we have our hands good
remember get them a little closer
together thumbs down the middle good
okay and then stance is always important
so scoot back just a little bit give it
a little bit more there you go we've
been from the waist Bend those knees
perfect and then when we take the club
up remember we're going to turn that
body try not to use all arms we use the
body and then we use those wrists to
make that nice L shape that we talked
about okay and then so go ahead and
start from the beginning again and try
that on your own and swing on through
we got that turn we got that L and then
sweep under close try it one more time
one more time I've been practicing this
and I swear I'm gonna get it yeah you're
popping them up in there really nicely I
would okay so here we go okay and that
good turn left arm straighter there you
go
okay I
promise I've been practicing though
and sweep under the ball there you go a
little better
thank you Lindsay you have been great at
trying to teach me we appreciate you and
you guys can get the same lesson
yourself from here they have baits as
well you can share them folks for about
45 bucks an hour you can split that with
your friends as well if you'd like and
find out more about their summer Academy
as well for children on our website
8newsnow.com we're not live from Topgolf
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now